my question to you is what is your line
of action if verdict comes in pts
favor and the government says we don't
follow it or whatever they come up with
because they are clearly trying to avoid
it what do you do what I you must have
thought something in your mind look when
when I dissolve my two assemblies
we got the top lawyers we looked at the
Constitution every lawyer in Pakistan
has said
that the moment you dissolve your
assemblies no government elections have
to be held within 90 days I mean this is
UN ambiguous there is just no doubt
about this thing so the moment you get
out of 90 days you are what in violation
of the Constitution and it is one of
those violations where once you get out
of 90 days who decides when
so if the government says in October
well why not in December why not next
year so the moment
General Zaya got out of the 90 days when
he came into power and he said I will
hold elections in 90 days the moment he
got away he lost for 11 years
so but so if the government if the
government does not accept the Supreme
Court verdict means it is now violating
the Constitution
then the the Supreme Court could slap
contempt on the government
and let me assure everyone that the
entire people of Pakistan will be
standing with the Supreme Court and what
does PTI plan on doing it are you
planning on going back on roads what's
the line of action no I think it just
won't be PTI you will have the lawyers
Community all the legal Community will
be standing on one side because there is
just no way you can the Constitution
leaves no doubt that the elections have
to be held in 90 days so therefore it
will be very difficult to defend anyone
who then
uh things that the elections can be
delayed just because the government is
petrified of losing the elections
because all opinion polls show that they
are going to be decimated therefore
there are there they just are running
scared of the election and they're
willing to even violate the constitution
and this was very nicely leans into the
next question that I have you have been
demanding all extensions the moment you
left the government uh you're basically
ousted
um and all the bipols you have swept you
have gone like seven six zero in your
own election
um and you have expressed multiple times
that you are looking to sweep the
elections two-thirds majority is what
you're looking for and you have also
said in your previous interviews last
year
um that we will not accept the result if
we don't get that so my question to you
specifically would be
um will you accept this election result
if you don't get outward uh the majority
and you know will be forced to make
coalition government are you confident
of free and fair elections I I have
never said that I will not accept the
election results if we don't get
two-thirds majority
uh all I have said is that right now if
you look at the opinion polls you look
at the by-elections where despite total
support by The Establishment and the
election commission
the 12-party Coalition has has only won
seven out of 37 PTI is 130 by-elections
so
it reflects that the PTI is going to
sweep the elections and hence the
government's care of Elections and
running away
but I can't say what the elections would
be you know whether I will accept the
results or not because we don't know
what the the election commission is
totally controlled by the government as
is obvious in the Supreme Court the
election commissioner had no
constitutional right to prolong the
elections they could not have announced
the election in October this is a
violation of the constitution in fact
the election commission should be held
in contempt because the Constitution is
clear their job was to hold the
elections when as required in the
Constitution they couldn't have given a
date in October so my point is that we
will see what happens in the elections
um I can't say whether we'll accept the
result or not because I don't know what
will happen in the elections and how the
election commission and the
establishment will behave I don't know
going forward and you obviously in the
last 12 months you have been talking
about military's role have you planned
in restructuring civil military
imbalance that we are seeing how do you
plan on working on that
uh the
look Pakistan has to change where we are
stuck right now Pakistan is stuck in the
worst economic crisis in our history
now if we have to to get out of this
crisis Pakistan has to
completely be restructured
we have to
our governance system has to change
completely
we have to have rule of law in this
country to create the enabling
environment to attract investment in
this country because we have hardly any
investment coming in our biggest source
of investment overseas pakistanis
they're about
uh 10 million overseas pakistanis
their GDP is more than in dollars is
more than the GDP of Pakistan
the 16 000 U.S American Physicians
Pakistani American Physicians their net
worth is 200 billion dollars
the 10 10 rich Pakistani businessmen in
U.S have net worth is 25 billion dollars
just the money is sent out from Pakistan
from pakistanis
to the bay where they have brought
property in Dubai
twenty thousand pakistanis a property
worth 10.4 billion dollars in Dubai so
now
number one why is money going out of
Pakistan
you know dollars going out
number two how can we attract the the
huge uh uh 10 million pakistanis with
dollar deposits dollar uh earnings how
can we attract that investment into
Pakistan that is the two issues and that
can only happen if we fix our governance
system but I'm specifically asking about
a civil military imbalance that has you
know caused so much grief in the last
one year as you cleared mentioned the
first answer specifically keeping to
civil military imbalance how do you look
at that look this is the Civil military
imbalance cannot work
uh if you want to improve Pakistan I
mean the current civil and Military
imbalance has to change if you want to
Pakistan to get out of this mess and by
that I mean rule of law you cannot have
a system
where the the Prime Minister has the
responsibility but he does not have the
authority to implement his policies
because that Authority is shared with
the military
there's no doubt that there's a role of
uh you cannot wish away the role of
military in Pakistan because it's
entrenched for 70 years but you need
that balance if you do not have that
balance you cannot have that governance
system that governance system is needed
now for Pakistan Survivor you can only
attract investment in Pakistan if you
have rule of law in the country out of
the 140 countries in the world
Pakistan's rule of law indexes 129. so
in if you have so basically if you don't
have rule of law you can't attract
investment without investment Pakistan
is stuck in this debt trap we are stuck
we're just taking loans to pay back
loans it's almost like a domino effect
like everything is collapsing so the
point is the way we stand today unless
we completely reform our governance
system and base it on rule of law I
don't think you know any economic you
can come up with the best Economist but
in these this environment no economic
policy is going to work right right
um so going on from there um in the
March 25th on your address in the Lahore
which you had like a such a massive
crowd uh you talked about reforming the
country as you presented the standpoint
economic agenda could you be more
specific about those reform agendas and
what would you have done differently if
you were still in power right now like
in the last 12 months the only thing
different would have been to impose rule
law look I have seen countries I mean I
have spent a lot of time in in England
as a professional cricketer and then I
went to University before
so the big difference in countries that
are prosperous and the ones that have
high levels of poverty is only one rule
of law
but that's a very is it a very generic
very broad level thing which is why I'm
specifically asking in terms of
immediate concern that we have like
Protestant economy look how would you
look at that economy is completely
connected with rule of law which then
establishes uh gives the enabling
environment for investment
Pakistan is very fortunate that it has
which I started in the beginning 10
million overseas Pakistan is earning in
dollars it's very fortunate now at the
moment all we rely on our remittances
from overseas pakistanis we can we we
cannot attract their investment
why can't we attract the investment
because they do not have confidence in
our judicial system and the rule of law
so once if they don't have confidence
they will go and invest in Dubai in
Malaysia anywhere else but not here
and this is our biggest handicap because
what is the problem of Pakistan it's our
current account deficit our problem is
that we have more dollars going out than
coming in now how are you the question
is how can we attract dollars in in
Pakistan the number one way of course is
exports but if we start from say if we
have power from day one it's going to
take time before we you know get the
industry going we get sort of all the
country gate towards export we are at a
midst of a quite a you know upheaval in
our region going on right now we also
have to balance between China you know
often we have in people say we are
Chinese Colony then we have America on
one side then we have hostile neighbor
on the Eastern Front we have security
concerns on the Western Front
specifically speaking on these foreign
policy issues very immediate ones
um how do you see that how do you plan
on working towards them considering we
have had the whole conspiracy you know
thing had been going on look
foreign policy number one has to be for
the benefit of your own population
Every Nation makes his foreign policy of
for the interest of its people so that's
the beginning now what is in the
interest of Pakistani people do you have
a foreign policy where we
get out of any conflicts like afran
Jihad like war on terror I mean these
conflicts cost us a lot
we suffered especially the war on terror
80 000 pakistanis died we had billions
over 100 billion lost to the economy
because you know
who wants to invest in a country which
is considered the most dangerous in the
world that terrorist attacks going on so
we learned one thing that we do not want
to get involved in other people's
conflict number one and then why should
we exclude ourselves like in the Cold
War we became part of the U.S Bloc but
that meant that the Russia and Central
Asian countries which we we can which
would be great trading partners for
Pakistan even Afghanistan all that
became in the others Affair and out of
our reach of trade so why not have a
foreign policy like India India has a
very mature foreign policy it is trading
with the U.S it is trading with China it
is getting cheap oil from Russia so
India's foreign policy benefits us
people it's kept down its inflation
because it got oil from Russia at
discounted price we on the other hand we
had negotiated discounted price but our
government went and the new government
came in and they just didn't pay any
attention to it as a result we had to
pay high oil prices which led to higher
inflation and which led to poor poverty